And
then I said, whoa!
And then she said, whoa!
Isn't that so funny?
Oh my god.
You're like so funny.
Oh my god, it's like I can tell you everything.
It's like I can tell you all my thoughts and my feelings and just...
Can you be my therapist?
Nah, I don't wanna... I don't wanna do my job.
I just wanna sit here.
What?
Is everything... Okay, we're good.
Hold on.
Hold on, you guys.
Um... Oh, I wish I had like... The sound of like a... Like, you know... Oh gosh, what's it called?
Uh... The... When you move something really old and it kinda like... It sounds like a boulder.
It's like...
That's what I was gonna... Hold on.
I'll just do it in my voice.
Not creaky.
It's like... How do you say...
Uh... I can't... I... It's... It's like a...
It's like a boulder.
Like moving a tomb.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That, that, that, that, that, that, that.
Hold on.
Why am I like so far forward?
I'm like leaning so forward.
Okay, let me get up.
I push my chair away.
I'll move.
I'm so small.
Wait, let me move my mic too.
Um...
Sorry.
I have to like lean in cause my mic is...
Is low.
It's here.
My arms kinda cross.
Do your job.
Body.
Anyway.
Um...
I'm going to do the bow to the bow.
Hello, everybody.
Hi.
I'm home.
Wait.
I shouldn't be saying...
You should be saying...
So if I say...
If I say...
Wait.
If I say tadaima, you guys say...
Ok.
Good.
You see my hand?
I'm giving an okay symbol.
Ok.
Wait.
I haven't said it yet.
I haven't said it.
Ok.
Ready?
Oh wait.
Let me...
Let's do a role play.
Hold on.
Wait.
Which...
Is it...
Is it following me?
I thought I turned that off.
Hold on.
Let me change some settings.
I had to...
I had to change things and then I forgot to save the settings.
Wait.
Did I change it?
Can't remember.
Wait.
Please.
Hold on a moment.
Please help.
Where is it?
I should...
I thought I turned it off.
Please.
Hold.
Please help.
Gosh.
Maybe...
What if I do this?
I'm frozen!
Oh!
No!
Ok, we are fine?
No...
I don't know what I'm doing!
Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey
Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey Mickey
Oh wait, I can be that frog!
Okay, I give up.
I give up, I give up.
Let me get rid of my desk.
Now I'm like really floating, hold on.
I'll make myself a little bit bigger.
I don't like the... I don't like the... the coloring that Waterdough does, but...
It is what it is.
Ta-da!
Hang on, let me adjust my mic again.
Oops, sorry, my arms go crazy.
My arms go crazy!
Anyway, I'm back you guys!
Hello!
I got Mokopi, and I like put it together just today.
Cause I was like...
What if I just...
What if I...
What if...
What if I use it?
Cause I got it, and it came...
And I have all of my technology working at once.
I can't really clap though.
It's not perfect.
It's definitely...
A very...
Home...
3D...
Setup.
That's for sure.
But...
Yeah.
All my technology.
All my technology!
Yeah!
Wait...
First!
Yeah!
Oh, yeah!
Um...
Thank you guys for all the welcome backs.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Um...
Uh...
Sorry for any awkward clipping.
Like, my sh...
My arms...
It's just gonna have...
That's just how it'll be.
But, when I have my actual 3D debut...
It'll be...
Much...
Nicer.
Don't worry about it.
It's just 3D things.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Happy...
Birthday...
PH423R!
Happy Birthday!
I wish that I could say that my voice was better...
After...
Being gone, but...
Um...
Sorry, guys.
It's not...
It's not any better.
I thought that maybe having the break would...
Make it a little bit better, but...
It really didn't.
So, I'm sorry.
I still can't sing a song...
For you.
So sorry.
You worked a lot, didn't you?
I did!
Some things...
I can talk about.
I cannot talk about.
NG, NG, NG.
But...
I can talk about some things.
Let me...
Scoot a little bit more...
Since I'm...
Falling...
Oh!
Nope.
That's not what I wanna do.
That's...
Oh!
That's better.
Um...
What else was I gonna say?
Yeah.
So...
I will...
Talk about things.
And I also wanna watch the state of play.
And...
Um...
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you for all the super tattoo guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
She's so tall.
Yeah, I am!
Um...
I can touch the ceiling!
Oh!
Nothing spilled.
We're okay.
Carefully put that somewhere else.
Carefully...
Put that...
In another location?
No...
Um...
I'll probably sit later.
If that's okay.
Uh...
Well, I'll set for sure for the state of play.
Um...
But first I wanna tell you about my stories.
Where I've been up to.
I'm sure you guys seen some stuff on Twitter and were just like...
Ooh...
What's happening?
Where?
I wish I could stop the camera.
Sorry, it's still bothering me.
Hold on, let me look one more time.
Uh...
I don't know...
I'm so like...
I'm...
Oh!
Wait, what is that?
Go away.
3D arrows.
They appear.
Here boy, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Sorry I missed it right before my trip.
It feels like forever since I've...
I feel...
I feel like...
Even more awkward than usual.
Because first of all, I'm in...
I'm in...
Oh...
I'm clipping through my body.
It's just ghost things, you know?
First of all, I'm in 3D.
And then second of all, it's because I...
Uh...
What's the word?
Oh!
I feel...
Because it's been so long since I've...
Streamed.
So it feels like...
Forever, forever.
Fuzzy happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Happy birthday.
And it's a little awkward.
Because I'm having to...
Watch out for everything.
Especially you.
You guys.
Having to watch out for you guys.
We missed you?
Really?
Did you?
Did you miss me?
Even a little bit?
Did you?
Hmm?
Did you miss me?
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you!
Thank you for the...
Maybe a little bit?
What's it like seeing me in home 3D?
How's it feel?
Stick'em up!
Oh!
That doesn't really work.
This is actually my new 3D tool.
So...
But the lighting is a little...
I don't know how...
I couldn't fix it in time.
I'm sorry.
Not what I was having trouble with before stream.
Some other stuff.
But...
Yes.
So...
I went to Japan again.
And I...
Oh my gosh.
So many birthdays.
I think I'm just gonna have to do like a general...
Happy birthday.
Everybody that I miss.
Will...?
Happy birthdayaaa!
We- We- We- We- We- We We- We debts- Weину!
We-
That many birthdays probably.
My left hand seems to be mostly fine, or... Yeah, my left hand seems to be mostly fine.
My right hand is having some issues.
Such is the way of 3D.
Thank you.
Thank you for the very cute...
Very cute as a thumbnail.
Thank you, thank you.
Kung Fu action?
Why do I trip?
Why do I do that?
You're that ninja.
But yeah, so I went...
And I can tell some stories.
Why do I feel so awkward?
I don't know.
I feel so awkward.
Maybe I feel so exposed, you know?
Like, I feel like I have to just keep moving.
And grooving.
And schmoving.
Um...
I went...
For...
Two...
Almost two...
Plus one finger.
Come on.
Cambare.
Two.
No, that's three.
Pick number two, my lord.
About two weeks, yes.
Pick...
Pick number three, my lord.
Can I do it?
It's really struggling.
Maybe with this hand.
Nope.
I give up.
Um...
And...
Oh my gosh!
You guys...
I have to talk about...
What's his name?
No, I wrote it down.
I watched a movie on the plane.
I have to talk about...
John Wick!
Oh!
Oh my god!
It was so good!
Oh my gosh!
John!
No, not Alan Wake.
Not that...
That's the...
That's a game.
That's a video game.
I watched John Wick.
And at first...
I feel like I've always said that it's really good.
But I was like...
I'm scared.
And I...
Luckily, I knew that the dog...
Was gonna happen.
But I...
So, I was prepared.
I was prepared for that.
Hold on.
Hold on a second.
But...
Why is my hand so messed up?
Stop it!
But, uh...
Um...
The movie itself was actually so good.
They only had the first one...
And the fourth one.
So...
I could only...
I only watched the first one...
Cause...
I'm not gonna skip...
Three movies.
That would be ridiculousness.
The first one is the best IMO.
Is it?
Okay.
Wait.
So it doesn't get better from you?
It's not gonna get any better.
It's a classic.
It was so good.
It was so, so good.
Four is peak?
Four is better.
Should we do a watch-a-lock?
Of all of them?
Should we?
I wanna watch the first one again.
I was like...
I need to talk to everybody about this movie.
I need to talk to people about John Wick.
Not Alan Wake.
Is Keanu Reeves in that game too?
Why do I keep thinking?
Why do I keep thinking that?
No?
Yes?
No.
He's not.
No, he's in Cyberpunk.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Hold on.
I just noticed something.
Be every...
I'll still be here, I mean.
But I need to fix something.
I just noticed something.
Uh-b-b-b-b.
Don't mind me.
Wait, how do I fix this?
How do I fix this?
Wait, here.
She's gone.
I ghosted you.
Actually, I'm going to sit down.
Is that okay now, you guys?
Um, where is it?
Where is it?
Yes, thank you for your permission.
Hold on, I'm still trying to fix this.
I just have to figure out where it is.
Oh, there it is.
Ha ha.
Okay, I fixed something.
I'm going to become bigger now.
I don't know why my right arm is acting so buggy.
You're just going to have to get over it, I think.
Let me put my desk.
Three, two, one.
How do I fit?
I want to be just a little big.
Closer.
Like this.
Ah.
You can see my tooth.
Maybe this is fine.
Nah, here is fine.
This is probably better.
Big man's a jump scout.
Wait.
Why is my arm so messed up?
Jump scout.
Wait, wait, wait.
Nice paint and nails.
Thank you.
Wait.
Like, my keeps getting in the way.
Why is it now tracking?
Sorry, I'm no, I'm no doobie.
I'm no, I'm no doobie.
Give me bro fist.
Wait.
Fit.
Nope.
Uh.
Go-go.
Go-go gadget.
Fist.
It doesn't work.
Go-go.
Ah.
There you go.
Yeah.
Bumpy.
Yeah, I'll get rid of my desk so that you can see more, I suppose.
It's kind of embarrassing, though, when it doesn't work, so.
Don't be so judgmental, okay?
Bumpy.
Bumpy, bro.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um.
So, yeah.
We'll do a watch along then of...
The John Wick.
But those were my trip.
It was mostly cold.
Cold!
And rainy.
So much rain.
But cold.
That was what I wasn't expecting.
Like, um.
It's kind of an unusual, no?
For, like, the end of May?
I think?
You need John Cat.
Who's that?
I can see cavities.
No, you can't!
I brush my teeth every day.
Oh, it's almost summer.
I know!
And it was so chilly.
I had...
I packed...
I packed just a few sweaters.
Because, uh...
Oh, that's Bebo's cat.
Wait!
I'm not there yet!
I'm not there yet, you guys.
You're...
You're jumping ahead.
Of my stories, okay?
But, um...
Yeah.
Oh!
So, I get there.
And then, uh...
Day...
After?
No.
The day after after.
So, I get there.
Man.
Two days later.
I...
Have a practice with Koyo.
Um...
Koyori.
Uh...
Kamono friends.
V...
V Kemono.
Kem...
Kemo...
V...
Uh...
Kemo V...
That...
Um...
I met with her to practice.
If you didn't see...
Hold on.
Let me post.
D-d-d-d...
Koyo...
Graduation...
Uh...
What?
How do you say?
It wasn't...
It wasn't her actual, like, last stream.
It's like a...
How did she title it?
How did she...
Farewell party...
3-d...
3-d party...
There you go.
You should go watch.
It was really fun.
Um...
She and I...
Uh...
Practiced...
We practiced our dance.
But she kept shocking me.
Every time.
Every time we touched.
She shocked me.
Every time.
Literally.
Uh...
It got to the point where...
She...
Would get close to me.
And we had this...
Electric...
Energy.
Yeah.
And...
Um...
Yeah.
She was, like, trying to use her phone to...
To...
What's the word?
To operate...
The music.
And she was, like...
Mintz, I need you to turn my phone on.
Because...
She kept shocking herself.
I think it's the...
I think it's, like...
Her fur...
On her...
Fluffy, fluffy tail.
I think it was her fluffy, fluffy fur.
Mmm...
Fluffy tail.
That was so staticky, though.
Not the F-boy, though.
Uh...
Oh!
Where'd I go?
Did you guys see anything?
Wait...
What just happened?
I don't know what just happened.
I didn't touch anything.
I don't know.
Anyway...
Um...
But then...
Oh my gosh.
Originally, when we practiced...
Um...
She...
Wanted to have a part where...
She jumped over my back.
Like...
Like a frog.
Like a hopscotch.
And, um...
We ended up having to scrap that.
Because we were like...
Maybe...
The Japari Park staff...
Will get mad at us.
So...
Leapfrog?
Yeah, what did I say?
What did I say?
Huh?
Oh, I said hopscotch.
Oh.
Yeah.
Like a...
Leapfrog.
Yep.
We...
We cut that.
Because...
Uh...
We were scared that...
Park staff would get...
Upset at us.
So...
But we tried it.
And...
She like...
Was able to jump on my back.
Pretty good.
Yeah, yeah.
Hmm...
But then...
Uh...
For a more infamous...
Um...
Spot.
Uh...
She was like...
Mito...
Mito, do you know how to...
Uh...
Cartwheel?
And I was like...
Yes...
Hmm...
I know how to cartwheel!
You!
And...
Um...
Yeah...
Uh...
Essentially...
I showed her my cartwheel...
And...
Wait, hold on.
Let me...
Restart something.
Hold on.
I'm gonna disappear again.
But, uh...
She said...
Show me your cartwheel!
And I did.
And she was like...
You know what?
It might be actually...
Better if...
You know...
I do a proper cartwheel...
And...
Yours is bad.
And I was like...
What do you mean bad?
Hey!
Oh, hold on.
I gotta reset.
Oh!
You hear that?
What do you do?
Did you hear that?
But, uh...
Why is...
Why am I looking up so high?
Hmm...
I might go to 2D...
If it keeps being annoying.
Sorry, guys.
I'll just...
I'll just adjust.
Um...
So, yeah.
That was a great cartwheel.
Coyle really showed everyone your stuff.
I told her.
I was like...
Everyone's gonna see...
Coyle.
Everybody's going to see my panties.
And...
That...
She said it was okay.
That was her.
She.
She said...
Oh!
It's okay.
Maybe.
That one...
So, that one was on purpose.
We decided to go with that bit instead.
But...
Then I ended up seeing my panties everywhere.
And that wasn't intentional.
Just the one.
Just the...
Just the single one.
Alright.
There we go.
Just the single one.
What was that?
Oh!
Kaz, what are you doing in here?
Oh.
What are you doing in here?
What happened?
Wait.
I thought you wouldn't be able to see anything.
The camera followed you.
That's because I couldn't turn off the settings.
What did you see?
I saw London.
I saw France.
No!
How much?
How do I stop the camera from following me?
How do I stop it?
I tried.
I thought I turned it off earlier.
Or rather...
I found it earlier.
Now I can't find it again.
Oh.
I thought because it was on my face, you wouldn't see anything.
Hot dog.
Pause knew what she was doing.
Ow!
I turned around.
I was petting her.
Anyway.
Erase.
Erase from...
Erase from your mind.
Erase.
What's it gonna be?
Wait.
Beep, beep, beep.
What's it gonna be?
Erase, erase, erase, erase.
Anyway.
Yeah.
Well, wow.
I was just talking about accidental...
accidental flashing.
I was just talking about accidental flashing.
Here we go.
I'm embarrassed.
I wasn't ready to show you.
Sorry if I'm a little low energy today.
Also, guys, I'm still jet lagged.
So...
Yeah.
And...
Um...
My brain is all...
Because I can't...
I had to write down some stuff.
I couldn't remember anything.
Thank you for the demonstration.
Actually, I have a sponsored stream.
This week.
Um...
I'm very excited about it.
Because it's a company that I like.
So I was like...
Wow.
And it's a series that I've wanted to get into.
Um...
So...
I guess I could say it.
I guess I could probably say it.
It's probably okay.
But, um...
I got...
A sponsor from...
From...
Marvelous!
For...
Rune Factory!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait.
Yes.
Hold on.
Let me double check.
I saw someone say Rune Factory.
And now I'm like...
Wait.
Was that right?
I'm so tired, you guys.
I just woke up.
There's a new one.
Is there not?
Wait, hold on.
Let me double check.
Why am I so like this?
Don't...
Don't look...
Sponsor people.
Please.
I'm too tired.
Wait.
Yes!
I knew it.
I was like, it is Rune Factory.
Yeah.
New, new.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's the new Rune Factory.
I knew it.
I shouldn't doubt myself so much.
Yeah.
I'll know all about it on Saturday when I stream.
The sponsor.
Hmm.
So.
Yeah.
Wait.
This is my dream.
Oh.
As a huge Komono Friends fan, it was so cool to...
You got to hang out with Koyo Dyer and Hululu.
Yeah.
It was so...
They were so nice.
Honestly.
It was so...
Surreal.
And thank you for the...
Thank you.
It was so surreal.
Meeting Hululu.
You know?
I think it happened at the same time that Paz jumped down.
So.
But, um...
Yeah.
Meeting Hululu with So.
Because, you know, she's like kind of legendary.
With Grapecon.
So, I was like, wow.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm meeting the legend.
The Grapecon wife.
And
she really is.
Yeah.
Who's Hululu?
She's a penguin.
Penguin character.
Slash.
Because...
Camel V exists.
So, slash VTuber.
From Kimono Friends.
And if you know the story...
If you don't know.
First of all.
If you don't know the story about Grapecon, you should look it up.
But if you do know the story, then you know that...
That...
How famous...
How famous Hululu is.
So...
Yeah.
I got to meet her.
And Dire Wolf was so cute, too.
And, of course, Koyo.
I love Koyo.
Yeah.
The stream was really fun.
There was...
There's a part in the stream where, like...
We play...
The game where you...
Close your eyes and you run away from the...
From the...
Or you try to catch the peep.
You...
You blind...
You close your eyes.
And you have a bat.
And you try to whack the people.
From hearing them.
I'm not describing it very well.
Just go watch the stream.
And...
We had...
We had rubber chickens...
On our feet.
And...
I watched back on the stream.
Because I was just like...
Gosh.
I want to know what they sound like.
These rubber chickens.
What do you guys hear?
And...
You guys don't understand...
How...
Actually...
Loud...
Those chickens were...
In the room.
They were...
Even more loud than it was on the stream.
They were so...
Loud...
It was...
My brain...
Yeah...
It was so...
Oh my gosh.
It was so, so stinking loud.
Oh, sorry.
I just...
I just crossed my legs.
And I realized...
I don't think I can do that.
Because my skirt will...
Let's see if I can...
Oh...
You see it...
It's okay.
It's fine.
Oh, yeah.
So it was super duper...
Super duper loud.
And...
Um...
Uh...
But...
Please watch the stream yourself.
Oh, let me link it again.
Koyo...
I don't know why my arms are doing this.
Uh...
Koyo...
3D...
Graduation...
Celebration.
Yes.
Oh...
And so...
Um...
That was also my first time...
Using my new 3D.
So it was a little bit of a sneak peek.
But I also didn't realize how floofy my skirt was.
I didn't know.
Apparently even when I jump...
Wait, let me try jumping.
Let me try jumping real quick.
Let's see if it does here.
Okay.
Yeah, I have to like recalibrate or something.
I wonder if it's...
Oh!
Oh, that was actually me crossing.
What if I take it off my head?
Okay, let me try.
3...
2...
1...
Maybe there.
I have to really jump though.
I have to really jump.
Oh!
Like a jellyfish.
Where did my chair go?
That's fine.
There we go.
Yeah.
She's it.
I sit.
I sit, I sit, I sit.
Um, another thing that I noticed in Japan was...
Choco Minto is so popular right now.
So, there was lots of chocolate mint things.
All around, and I was like...
I feel so special.
Um, you got your Switch too?
Oh!
Me too.
I was like, what if I play Mario Kart World today instead?
But I don't think...
I don't think I have the mental capacity.
I don't think I have the mental capacity to do anything.
Um...
And then I did a lot of things that I can't say yet.
Can you throw it back?
If I...
Oh, you really...
Oh, it's a different one.
Oh, that was the sulky one.
Wasn't there one earlier?
Oh, pyro bug!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you for the big dodo.
Thank you so much.
Throw it back.
Okay, hold on.
Why do I look like a shrimp?
What?
Wait...
What if I...
I can't do it!
I'm gonna spread my legs apart more.
They need an ass tracker, clearly.
They need to include that.
I tried.
Clearly an oversight, absolutely.
What were they thinking?
Sorry that it's so scuffed, you guys.
What about the armpits?
What about my armpits, huh?
What about them?
I have to be careful when I...
When I pull my chair.
Wait, so...
Like that.
Hello, Mito.
Hello!
Hello, hello!
Well, now I'm gonna take them.
I needed to get more...
The arms are getting worse and worse.
Oh, maybe it's because of my...
Oh, yeah!
What if I take off my head?
Hold on...
Off with her head!
Guys, am I spooky?
Am I spooky?
Oh...
I think I'm broken.
Wait...
Guys, I think I broke the model.
I...
I think I need to fix it myself.
One moment, please.
Do...
It's kind of hard.
Are you trying to see my back or something?
That's better.
Oh, yeah, baby.
Yes, you wanna see my back?
That's my back.
You never see it.
Right there.
Do your stretches, everybody.
Do your stretches.
Okay, okay.
I'm just clipping through my head.
Taiskaru!
Taiskaru.
Ooh.
Okay.
But yeah, I think I was saying that there's things that I cannot say yet for my trip.
So, you'll go.
Eventually.
Eventually, eventually.
Sorry, I'm having to fix my sleeves here.
Too much movement.
I'm all in due time.
Yes.
What could it be?
What finger is that?
There we go.
That wasn't the middle finger.
Wait.
Can I do my middle finger?
One.
This.
This one.
Oh.
Nope.
That's everything but my middle finger.
Guys, I'm not even putting...
I think my...
I'm possessed.
Oh.
Nope.
not.
Rock guy.
Oh.
What?
Baby's first motor skills.
Oh.
Yeah.
Baby's first motor skills, everybody.
It's a little scuffed today, okay?
Hey, bear with me, bear with me.
Oh, oh my gosh, you guys.
I have to talk about how much I hid in my hotel.
I have to talk about how much my hotel was terrible.
I won't say what the hotel is, but I won't be staying there again.
Oh boy, we'll tell horror stories.
Okay, first of all...
Some days at 8 a.m.
There would just be like banging, banging, banging, banging, banging, banging, banging.
I don't know what it was.
I don't know.
I don't... I didn't... I don't know.
It was just bang, bang, bang, bang, bang.
At 8 a.m.
and it would have... it would last for about like 15 minutes.
I have... hold on.
Hold on.
I have a video.
I don't know why my arms are like this.
Sorry, guys.
Hold on, I have a video.
I can promise you, my arms don't do this.
You saw my 3D.
My arms didn't do this before.
I think it's just today.
Hold on, I have a video.
Because I was like, what the hell?
Why is this banging?
And it was like, consistent.
Okay, hold on.
Let me try this one.
Oop.
I'm listening.
I don't know if it'll catch, if it'll, if it'll show up though in the video, in the, in, for you guys.
Can you hear this?
Can you hear it?
It says, it's up as, as, as, as up as I can make it.
A little.
Slightly, yeah?
And that's, that's on my phone.
Can you imagine what it sounded like in here?
Let me, let me, let me, I'll turn up my mic even.
Actually, let me turn off the noise gate, too.
Uh...
Uh, ha, ha, ha.
I'm gonna turn off noise gate.
Okay.
You're a soon.
Thank you.
Thank you, Blotch.
Okay.
All right, I turned up my volume a little bit.
And now, I will play the video for you.
Hotel's haunted, but not by me.
It's still going, but you can't really hear it.
Okay, it stopped.
Yeah.
Freaky, right?
And it would do this at... it would do this at like 8am.
Was it consistent?
Yeah!
Like boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
And let's see, this one I took at...
7.56am.
7.56, 7.54.
Wait.
This one you can hear well too.
And I think I go, what the hell is that?
Stop, stop, stop, stop.
I go, what the hell is that?
Hold on.
Let me turn off the noise gate again.
Okay, listen.
Oh, sorry.
Do you hear how loud that is?
It was so loud!
I should have filed a complaint, honestly.
I should have been like, what the hell, you guys?
What is this?
Oh, what the hell is this?
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Water heater.
I don't know.
Ah, it was freaky.
And it happened on like my first night there.
So I was like, oh no.
And, um, yeah, it's a hotel that I have always wanted to stay at.
I was like, oh, Nancy Jew.
Nancy, Nancy Dorusama.
Nancy, Nancy Chan.
Um, what was I saying?
Hold on.
Uh, yeah.
And, uh, Nancy's summer.
The real kind.
Yeah, it was a hotel I've always wanted to stay at.
But my view was total doo-doo.
And then the elevators were so terrible.
And, oh my gosh.
Speaking of the elevators.
Hotel VJF composed by Akira Yavok.
There was, there was a one time.
So there was, it was, it was a really big hotel.
It was a pretty big hotel.
And, uh, um, I, but the elevators were just terrible.
Even though there were so many elevators, they were so slow all the time.
And I was, uh, going to my room one night.
And it was me, and a dad, and his son, and some other guy.
And we were all waiting for the elevator to come.
And, uh, after like five minutes.
It took like five minutes.
It was, oh, it was so long.
Uh, there was, there was, there was finally an elevator that came.
And, the guy, the guy that was the solo guy, he gets on the elevator.
And then, pushes, pushes the closed door button on me and the dad's face.
We, we, we were like walking towards the door and it just shut in our faces.
And, we both look at each other.
Me and the dad.
And we're just like...
We were like, and we just go...
Uh, uh, and he goes...
Uh,
oh my gosh, it was the worst hotel.
The people were rude.
And, the hotel, the hotel was bad.
And, the, the elevators were slow.
And I was, I was just, I was like, I talked to the guy, I was just like...
The dad, I was like, that surprised me.
Why did he shut the door?
And he goes, I don't know.
Maybe he didn't see us.
Oops, sorry, that was my mints.
And I was like, what a, what an optimist.
I got more Mintia voice mints, because they're so good.
I went to, like, 20 stores to find these.
Hmm.
He can't see ghosts.
I think so.
I don't know if the guy that shut the elevator on us was Japanese.
But the, but the dad was Japanese.
Hmm.
So.
Yeah.
It was pretty funny, though.
We were just like, ah.
Because I was like, la la la, walking to the elevator.
And then, then just, it shuts on us.
And we're like, ah.
Ah.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
It was, it was not.
And then also, they would have, like, signs by the elevators in the morning being like, oh, by the way, the elevators are going to get really busy around this time.
So, um, so, uh, be careful.
Uh, we, we, we don't know.
Just, uh, deal with it, I guess.
It was so bad.
It was so, so bad.
Hmm.
But, um, I guess you'll wait.
Yeah, I, I guess.
It's times like these that I'm glad I used the stairs.
Oh, oh my gosh.
I forgot also.
Okay.
Like I said, it was a very big hotel.
One, I've always wanted to stay there.
Two, I got a super, super good deal on it.
Maybe because it's, nobody wants to stay there.
Who knows?
But, um, I'll give you an idea.
It's, and I'm going to say this.
If you know Japan, you know that, like, there's not very many, very many hotels that are, I guess, this, this big.
But, like I said, I got a super duper.
It was on sale, like, a lot.
So, it was super duper good.
And that's the only reason I stayed there.
Um, I'm not just blowing money on expensive hotels.
But, um, uh, I was on the 17th floor.
Okay?
The 17th floor.
All right.
17th.
Very high.
And I was, I, that's not even the highest, the highest, like, that's like halfway.
Okay?
That's like halfway.
One night, I'm sitting in my room.
And I, out of the corner of my eye, I notice something moving.
It was an ant!
An ant!
On the 17th floor of this hotel!
How?
Where did the ant come from?
How did an ant get onto the 17th floor of this hotel?
I'm so angry.
And it was, it was huge!
This sucker was ginormous!
Like, the size of my pinky nail.
And then, I was also walking down the hallway.
Sorry, I'm, I'm doing things with my fingies, but you can't see.
I was walking down the hallway, and on the ground, I, I look at the ground when I walk.
I'm looking down.
A second ant.
How?
How are there two ants on the 17th floor?
I'm so angry.
Same size?
Yeah, I took a picture of it.
I am never staying at this hotel ever again.
But yeah, that's why I couldn't take the stairs, you know?
I'm so tall!
But, I'm on a tall floor.
So.
Yeah.
At least it was on sale.
I know!
I'll never stay there again.
And I'm so disappointed because I was really looking forward to it.
Oh well.
Hmm.
Um, what else?
Uh.
Oh!
Um.
Now I can talk about...
Now I can talk about it.
So, I got to hang out with a certain wife of mine in Japan, of course.
I'm talking about the lovely Takanashi Kiara of Hololive English Myth.
And, um, I was hanging out with her.
And, uh...
Uh, we were both busy.
So, we couldn't really do like an off collab or anything like that.
I'm sorry.
Forgive me.
Um.
Uh.
Hopefully, we can collab again soon though.
I miss her.
I was kissing her on the head.
I was like...
Oh, kiwaba!
Um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, uh.
That's what I was doing.
I was like...
Um,
um, um, um, um, um, um, um.
It's fine.
You're on break.
Mmm.
True.
And, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, uh, actually, I didn't realize that she would be there.
But, uh, Koseki Bijou...
As you might have saw on Twitter, um, I got to meet her.
And I've...
I...
People have said before in the past, like, oh, you should talk to Bijou about DMC or anything And I was like, I don't think she knows who I am, you guys.
It's fine.
It's okay.
You know?
And...
But she knew who I was!
She knew!
I was so shocked.
I was like...
Me?
I was like, you know Watashi?
And so...
Minky is worldwide famous.
Oh, yeah.
Worldwide famous Minky.
But, um...
Yeah, uh...
She was showing me some DMC things on her bag.
And, uh...
And I was like, oh my gosh, these are so cute!
Where did you get them?
She was like, the Capcom store, girl!
You gotta go!
I was like, I will!
Oh my god!
And, um...
Uh, Kiara was like, what are you gonna do after this Minto?
Do you have any plans?
And I was like, well, I'm going to the Capcom store, apparently!
And, uh...
Um...
Biju was just like, do you want me to come with?
I was like, you...
You just met me today, but you wouldn't...
You wouldn't come with me!
I was so happy!
Oh my gosh!
I was like, you...
You wanna...
You wanna hang out?
Ah!
I was so happy!
Oh my gosh!
And it was so much fun!
I was...
It was so much fun!
And she's so cute!
She's...
So...
Cute!
People were like, oh, who's smaller?
Biju or Minto?
Uh...
I think...
Pretty sure, like, Biju is like...
Hold on...
Koseki...
I think she's like, 4'7", no?
Biju...
Height...
Koseki...
140 centimeters!
Yeah!
You guys...
She's very small!
She's smaller than me!
Actually...
Kiara...
Put us next to each other...
And she was just like, I see...
Just a little bit of a difference!
She's like, I see...
Just a little bit...
So yeah...
She's so...
She was so...
So cute!
Oh my god...
Um...
Actually...
Uh...
There was like, some other people...
There with us...
Uh...
I think like...
Her...
Manager?
I believe?
And after...
And Biju...
Left before...
Before like...
Uh...
We disbanded...
And...
Um...
I was like...
Now that she's gone...
I can be like...
She's so cute!
I didn't wanna...
Yeah...
Ponma...
Yes...
That was their name...
I was like...
CUTE!
I couldn't say it in front of her.
But I was like...
After she... After she left... I got to... I got to release... I got to release mine.
I was... I was...
PONMA CUTE?
Yeah...
Everybody's so cute.
I'm only surrounded by cute people.
But... And she gave me... She got like a box full of...
These like wooden... Wooden... How do you say?
Not keychains.
Pins?
Wooden pins... Like... The artwork is made out of wood.
Of... Different Capcom characters.
And she was like... Which one do you want?
And I was like... I want... Phoenix Wright.
Please.
And... She... She gave me that one.
She... She bought the whole box...
Just so that she could get Virgil.
She was like... She was like... I can't take any chances.
I have to get Virgil.
She's not wrong.
Yeah.
I got a couple... I posted on Twitter.
I got a couple... DMC plushies.
And then I got some blind...
Bag... Blind box things.
And...
Two of them were... Buttons.
And I got one of... Lady.
And one of... Dante with Lady.
So I was very... I was very pleased.
And... I got... There was... They were also doing a... Um... What's it called?
Uh... Uh... Like a summer... Version of the boys.
And... Um... All I wanted was Virgil.
What I got... I was like... All I want is Virgil!
If I get Nero... Of course I'll be so happy.
I love Nero.
If I get Dante... Of course I'll be so happy.
I love Dante.
But I just don't want V!
The desire sensor.
Ah... The desire sensor.
I don't want... I didn't want V!
Oh, sorry.
I'm falling over.
But sick boy.
I'm gonna give it to Mogu.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna give it to Mogu.
And then... Ah!
I'll have to go back and get some more.
So that I can...
Try...
For...
Virgil.
Yeah.
But yeah...
Let's see.
What else?
Uh...
I wanted to go to Disney.
To treat myself.
I was too tired for Disney.
So I didn't get to go.
Mmm...
What else?
Sorry.
Uh...
How did the 3D debut recording go?
I will have more about that...
Later.
But it went very good.
It was...
Um...
Everybody...
Said I was crazy.
Everybody saw my schedule and was like...
Girl, you're crazy.
How...
How did you do all of this?
In such a small amount of time.
And I said...
Um...
I just...
Did it.
Hmm...
Wait...
I'm trying to do ya...
Oh, there...
Hmm...
Ha-ha...
So...
Yeah...
It was a lot, but...
Oh my gosh...
This arm is really bugging out.
It's like going inside me.
How do I fix it?
Hmm...
Oh wait, maybe this is why.
Look, it's like inside me.
Wow...
My handshooo...
Whoa...
My arms are bugging out!
Well...
Can't even see my arm, Pritch, cause my arms are just bugging out.
Wait...
Whoa!
Why is it doing that?
Hm...
Hold on, let me reset again.
Da-da...
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da...
Are you guys ready to watch State of Play?
Let me reset.
I'm ready.
Da-da-ding!
I can't tell if that's better or not.
Nah...
I don't think it is.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha...
I don't think that's better.
Hm.
Hm...
It's fine.
Maybe.
Ya...
...
Let me...
Ugh...
Do I wanna stand up for this?
So I can be all excited for things?
Oh yeah, sorry, let me read it.
Da-daaaay!
I'll stand up.
Woo!
Sorry, I'm like... I'm spreaded.
I have to so that...
I can fix stuff.
There we go.
Everything good?
Everything not good.
My arm is all messed up.
Still.
I wish they made you T-pose in this, but they don't.
Yeah, see?
It should be like this arm, but it's not.
Hmm.
It's okay.
What's a little scuff, huh?
What's a little scuff?
Let me get...
the...
State of play up.
Da-da-da-da-da-da.
Ba-ba-da-ba-da-ba.
Ba-ba-da-ba-da-da.
Ba-ba-...
Oh, I can't... I just realized I didn't have BGM this whole time.
I'm so sorry.
It's just a podcast at this point.
Alrighty.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Um...
One moment.
Okay.
That...
Wait.
Is this it?
I think so.
Let me make sure.
Oh!
I think so.
Sorry.
Um...
Okay.
Then I do...
Wait.
No.
This is...
Now it's starting in the middle for some reason.
No, no, no.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, wait.
No.
This is...
This is what I do.
Studio.
Window.
Capture.
State of Play.
I was like, what is this?
Biju Koseki Height.
Sorry.
I didn't think it was playing.
Oh, you couldn't hear it.
That's funny.
I yelled for nothing.
I yelled for no reason.
Because you guys couldn't hear it.
Maybe that's good.
Let me get rid of...
This.
Maybe like that.
Let's see how that looks.
Let's get rid of YouTube a little bit more.
Make it a bit bigger.
Like that.
She's hearing voices.
I am.
I'm hearing the voices.
My arm.
My arm's also hearing voices.
I wonder why it's bugging out.
Can't tell why.
I probably would have to just recalibrate maybe.
Maybe.
Oh wait.
Maybe this.
Oh.
That looks better.
That already looks better.
Okay.
Hmm.
Let's not accidentally flash you guys.
Okay.
Are we ready?
Are we ready for state of play?
Only on purpose.
I'm gonna take off...
The finger tracking.
But now I have no finger tracking.
So sorry.
I'm just like...
I'm doing the robot.
She ripped off her fingies.
Yeah.
I'm in karate mode.
All right.
Let's watch state of play.
This is my first time watching.
This is an hour long.
Wait.
I have to stand for a whole hour?
I'll probably sit in the middle.
I'll be honest guys.
This is so long.
What if I just skip some of the things that I don't care about?
What if I skip some of the things that I...
Okay, I'm gonna sit.
Who is this?
What is this?
Is it Tetris?
The Tetris effect?
No spoilers.
Wait.
Is it actually Tetris?
No spoilers.
I'm not allowed.
Spaceman!
What is this?
I'm clapping.
I
can't tell what's going on in this at all.
What is happening?
Luminous Arise.
Have you guys...
Oh, I forgot to ask this before we started.
But did you guys watch the...
The state of play already?
Or...
Hello!
Yeah.
Not yet?
Not as much together then.
Ohhhh...
I'm gonna check and make sure the...
Yeah.
Prop is okay.
Okay.
Typical puzzle game stuff.
Only the first 10ish minute time.
You hated it?
What if I didn't do one though?
Thank you!
And enjoy the rest of the state of play.
Bye bye!
Bye!
Thank you!
Bye bye!
Wait, I can put the...
As I'm sitting.
What comes after dreaming?
Have you ever had a dream where you...
Have you ever had...
Have you ever had a dream where...
And then you...
And when you...
And then you had a dream...
And in that dream you...
Our third generation of Luna Filament...
And advanced generative AI...
Yes.
Oh man, I just had one plug my headphones.
We create life...
For our future...
Delphi Corporation.
Delphi!
What is this?
I missed the entire thing.
I took off my headphones.
Let's see about getting passed through to Earth.
Oh.
And why are these things trying to kill us?
Meow meow.
There you are.
Captured on PSY, bro.
Oh my god, it's Death Stranding 2.
Ooh, Capcom!
Definitely.
Whoa, whoa, hang on a second.
Don't you have a name or something?
She's D-I-7-5.
Get behind me.
Whatever she said.
I think I can help.
Wow.
Target identified.
Neutralized in place.
Neutralized us?
The baby from Death Stranding grew up.
Looks like we're gonna have to fight our way through.
Like, actually.
Bypassing first and second firewalls.
Hooking control protocol.
Dad's space.
Initiating hacks!
She's so cute, though.
Pragmata.
Cute!
Hey, uh, D-I...
I said I am D-I-0.
Okay, okay.
She's so cute, though!
How about we call you Diana?
Diana.
What?
Diana?
Just call her...
D.
Some...
Diana.
Oh.
Was this supposed to come out?
Wait, wait, wait.
It's real...
Real, lol.
It's...
It's real, lol.
We...
Wait, was this promised before or something?
It got shelved.
Oh, ho, ho, ho, ho.
That's so funny.
Oh, hey.
Today is Saturday, which means curry time.
Whoa!
Curry time!
Num, num, nummy!
What does that mean?
What is this?
Rotoscoping.
Okay, okay.
I'm getting dizzy.
Oh, my God!
Who's gonna die?
Romeo, listen up!
Romeo, roll me!
You're gonna die in 15 seconds!
Seriously?
Seriously!
Don't worry!
I made this just in case.
The Dead Gear life support system.
Don't move, okay?
What's happening?
Ehhh!
Wow, Osmosis Jones!
What's happening?
I'm really looking forward to cracking up.
I haven't cracked up recently.
From now on, you're dead man.
Romeo is a dead man.
I'm a dead man.
Oh.
They're like...
Jambos.
Oh!
I'm gonna die!
There's no way I'm dying!
Wait, the...
I actually like that they kind of did the bait and switch with the graphics.
Oh!
Whoa!
Romeo is a dead man.
Suda51 is...
...of 2026.
It feels very...
Oh my god!
Wait!
Oh!
Sorry.
We'll just let it play.
How's Grandpa's voice?
Are you like...
...a spirit?
I'm on your back!
Oh!
What?
Ah!
There it is.
Grasshopper.
Hahaha!
Ah!
There...
There it is.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Konnichiwa.
It's the man!
Oh, it's the man!
Yeah!
It's the man himself!
Suda51!
Wow!
He's not aged at all?
Yeah!
How old is he?
What does he do when he turns 51?
Wait, I'm gonna look up, but how old is he?
We are trying to make a team.
And why the title is Nomiya and Deadman?
Please be sure to wait.
It's over the 30th anniversary of the PlayStation, but thank you so much.
And then, let's see if you want to play.
He's 57!
He's 51.
51, 51, 51.
This is... it's Fatal Frame.
Not Fatal Frame, sorry.
It's... Silent Hill F.
Sorry.
I keep calling it Silent Hill Fatal Frame.
So in my brain, I'm like, Fatal Frame.
It looks so good.
This looks so good.
Oh my god.
It looks so good.
It's like everything I ever could have wanted.
Since I can't get another Fatal Frame.
Maybe.
Maybe one day.
It looks too good.
Oh my god.
Freaky.
Oh, it's like the mannequin...
Oh my god.
They look so good.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
I'm so excited for this game.
I'm so
excited for this game.
That's crazy creepy creepy creepy creepy creepy creepy...
Oh, oh, hell no.
Oh hell no.
Oh my God.
Oh, my God.
They said the thing.
The Higurashi thing.
Ryuki, she's 7.
Oh,
she's so cute.
She's so cute.
I wish I could just scream right now.
Oh, it looks so good.
I need to sit down.
It looks so good.
September 25th, that's so soon.
It's so soon.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I can sit back down now.
Sorry, I jumped out of my chair.
The castle has been sighted again.
The church's orders are absolute.
Oh, I want to play so bad.
These human sacrifices must be stopped.
We will track the ethereal castle.
Break its gates.
And exterminate the creatures that dwell within.
The demon lord himself will fall by our hand.
This mission will test the limits of your courage.
What is this?
You will face horrors beyond your darkest imagines.
It's not Castlevania.
It's like so Castlevania, but not.
Creatures born of pure darkness.
Bloodstained-a-vania.
Wait, bloodstained?
I thought...I was thinking of blood...bore.
Sorry.
Un, two, three!
Oh no, he's fun.
Oh no.
Well, they get David Hayter again.
Oh my God, the curry!
We'll be here, David Hayter.
I know he's in the...
We start our mission!
I know he's in the game.
Dark...soul...born...vania.
Bloodstained.
Bloodstained, the scarlet engagement.
Oh, I never played the first one though.
I just know David Hayter's in it.
The difference...the...the...the...the graphics difference between...
Between the cutscenes...
Right into the palm of my hand.
And the...gameplay is so funny.
It's giving me flashbacks to like Kingdom Hearts.
You know?
Oh, Bandai Namco.
Shinjuku that I'm seeing...
Are a hellscape I can't quite put into words.
You've somehow been sent back in time eight years.
But the situation here is critical.
I'm counting on you, AJ.
Oh, it's a Digimon!
It's a Digimon game.
Oh, cute!
I'll always be right here with you.
Who exactly are you working for?
I can't!
Okay, this is gonna sound really controversial.
You really don't know anything about the digital world?
The artwork is like a mix between Pokemon and Persona.
But I know saying Digimon and Pokemon...
Like comparing them is like...
You know?
But do you guys see what I mean?
Like that outfit is so...
Not Persona...
That was very...
Uh...
Do the Titans not care about the end of the digital world?
What's the name?
Not...
Uh...
What is Not Persona?
Shin Megami...
Shin Megami Tensei!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That outfit in particular.
I can't protect anyone.
We must protect the world from them.
Oh my god, she's so cute.
But some of these characters look like they're from Pokemon.
That's so strange.
Please, everyone!
Lend me your strength!
It's do-da-da-da-da-digimon.
You must fulfill our mission.
It looks so good.
Age it.
Everything's coming out so soon!
October!
Toei Animation, I went there!
Did you see my Twitter post?
I went there.
Patamon!
I went there!
Squeenix.
I went there.
Final Fantasy.
Oh my gosh!
You guys, I have a video to show you.
Oh, actually, I don't think I can show you the video.
I have a video to let you guys hear.
Because it's me in the bathroom, but I'm not going to the bathroom.
Can I pause this?
Okay, hold on.
Before I forget.
It's Final Fantasy related.
So, they announced...
Or rather...
The Akiba Atore is having currently...
A collab with...
Or rather...
Yeah, the...
I guess you call it a collab.
Is with the Final Fantasy Pixel Remasters.
And so...
I went to Atore to pee.
And...
Just listen.
This is the music.
So, they play...
When they do these, like, collabs...
They play the music of whatever...
That they're...
Collabbing with.
And...
This is what it was.
This was the soundtrack of my pee.
Hold on, I'm going to turn it up again.
Hopefully it's not too loud.
Okay.
Can you hear it?
I was like...
All I want to do is pee in peace.
Sorry, that's someone flushing.
I don't think anybody was going to the bathroom in this, though.
I think they were, like, washing their hands.
I think I checked.
I was like...
The pee final boss music.
Sorry, that made me think of that.
Because of Final Fantasy.
I was like, I have to...
I have to record this.
Okay.
Final Fantasy Tactics.
Oh, I saw, actually, people posting about this.
Because they had, like, the cute little chocobo plushies.
Your pee suddenly has a health bar.
Wow.
I could post the video.
It's not me going to the bathroom or anything, so don't worry.
Don't worry.
Hi, everyone.
Hiya.
And I'm Syd Schumann, here to deliver news and release dates for games coming to PS5 later this year.
Metal Gear.
Final Fantasy Tactics.
Call it the restroom, I'm fighting for my life type music.
The game will include two versions of the original PlayStation Classic.
The enhanced version, which features improved graphics, fully voiced dialogue, refined gameplay, and much more.
How many weird recordings do you have on your phone?
As well as the classic version, which brings a faithful recreation of the 1997 original to modern consoles.
Not everything I record is for posting.
Sometimes it's just for me.
Final Fantasy Tactics, The Evil East Chronicles.
The Evil East.
The Evil Lies.
And will be available for pre-order later today.
This next game is something really special.
When I first played it, I laughed so hard, I almost barfed.
Let's check it out.
You always take so many amazing things so proud of you.
Thank you!
Sorry, I just need to pee.
Oh, that was me when I went to the Atore.
Just go behind this bush, I'll wait.
What is...
I can do it right away.
Pee shy.
You can watch.
In baby steps, all you have to do is carefully place one foot in front of the other.
Which is easier said than done.
No.
This is rage bait.
I will not fall for this.
No.
It's a captivating, open-world experience filled with oddball characters.
A strand game.
You found it even without a map.
The best toilet on the mountain.
Oh, good.
No, I won't do this.
No, this is a game for streamers.
Definitely check this one out when it comes to PS5 on September 8.
I won't fall for your propaganda!
I won't do it.
Hirogami is a unique action-adventure title from Bandai Namco studio Singapore.
Oh, wow!
In this journey to save your origami home...
Ew!
... you'll transform into paper shapes with distinct abilities...
... including a paper airplane...
That's a bird.
A nimble frog.
A hearty armadillo.
And a powerful ape.
Master the art of folding when Hirogami arrives on PS5 later this summer.
What are birds if not plays?
Oooo!
Sid, why don't you tee this next one up?
Thanks, Sean.
The Hotshot series has been with PlayStation from the very beginning, and its latest installment...
Aww, yeah baby, they announced this before.
I'm so excited.
More Hotshot golf.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ooooooh!
Oh, Pac-Man!
Iconic Pac-Man?
PS5, September 5th.
Sorry, I'm clapping, but my hands are being weird.
Ninja Gaiden Ragebound is a challenging new entry in the long-running action franchise.
From the makers of the Blasphemous series, Ragebound stars dual protagonists from rival clans, forced to combine their souls and skills against a demon uprising.
Souls?
And long-time fans will really love the pulse-pounding soundtrack featuring guest composers from the original series.
Ooh!
Nice!
Not the barrel-throwing man!
I got one job!
Ninja Gaiden Ragebound arrives July 31st on PS5 and PS4.
Dun-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da!
Oh, way...
Wait, I kind of...
I kinda vibe with this.
Oh!
Secrets!
No, no.
Marco, get away from my mountain.
Wait, so there's a bencher?
Oh, no!
My gameplay got leaked.
Oh, hey, I'm gonna try it.
I'm gonna try it after stream.
That's all from us.
Vertical Death Stranding.
I know, I kind of vibe with it, though.
I kind of like it.
Nothing can prepare you for their next collection.
Arriving later this year.
We knew pretty early on that the game was fun to play.
People were excited about it.
A new game collection.
The most rewarding part of it is just seeing people react to it.
Hello, uh...
Cowabunga!
Mortal Kombat.
It was such a shock to see this game.
I was like, I can't believe this game exists.
It became something that added to the mystique of Mortal Kombat.
That's how I want to go.
Get eaten by a dragon.
Ow.
Oh, my God.
Don't hurt your talent.
Goodness gracious.
Real.
Thank you.
There was no template to make the games.
It's a bit of the Wild West.
Every part of that game is an expression of who we were and what we wanted to do.
Toasty... Toasty... Wishlist now... Toasty man, I don't know that one... Old
MK meme... Oh... Oh... That's a... Oh...
Wow... They've never made one before?
Really?
Huh... Fight Stick.
Fight Stick.
Oh... Oh... it's an enemy insurance.
That guy?
Know he's close... Where did he go?
We lost sight of the enemy...
We're under fire!
Enemy position on top.
Loading like this... That's a tradition!
All right, Commander!
Oh my god, I want to hug him too!
I want to hug him too!
Wait, what's this?
Wait, there's more?
I didn't even notice that guy was there!
Oh my god, he turned into a...
Online?
MGO online?
Wait, I want to watch it again.
Why am I saying MGO online?
I'm so stupid.
Sorry, I'm so tired.
My brain can't work.
Hold on, I want to watch again.
I'm saying ATM machine.
Control here.
We have evidence of an enemy...
Uh...
No, he's close.
What?
Uh...
The Crocs...
Oh, the Croccat looking so good!
We've lost sight of the enemy.
Find him!
Stinky!
Look how gross he is!
He's covered in everything!
We're under...
Oh!
Oh, they're like...
Oh, I was like...
I noticed he shivered and I was...
Or like...
He did like a weird movement.
I was like, what is he doing?
He's...
They're reading the magazine!
They're being little perverts!
Watch him.
I can't look at him!
Oh he looks so...
Oh!
He looks...
...
A-me.
His name's A-me.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, I can't look at him.
He looks...
Oh my gosh did you see where I come behind?!
Oh, gosh.
I'm okay.
No,
my trauma.
Wait, I kind of want to see how the fear looks.
Oh, I guess he can... I guess he'll look kind of similar.
Where, like, you can see his outline.
Sorry, my arms are broken because I've...
My arms are a little broken right now.
Wait, he's like...
Wait, they, like, ADR'd that.
His mouth's not moving.
You won't!
See?
He's talking, but...
But...
He's not moving his mouth.
He's just that talented.
There you go.
Sorry, I keep pausing.
Back to your own world.
I keep thinking of the old angles for this one.
It's so funny.
Yeah!
See you in hell!
I'll grind you into...
Show me Ocelot up the top watching us.
Show me.
Wookie, wookie, wookie!
Wait, I'm dancing with them.
Wait.
Hold on.
I'll do it again.
Hidden monkey!
Weezy monkey!
Ah!
He's the one!
He's holding that monkey!
Okay.
MGO!
They did it!
You guys, we can play!
We can play together.
MGO!
Okay, let me...
Before we continue, sorry.
Let me reset again.
I'm sorry.
I got all broken because I kept falling over.
You could say I was falling for a snake.
Reset.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I think that did it, actually.
Reset.
I'm better now.
Let me get my chair.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Ba-da.
Ba-da-da-da.
Spirit stones.
Spirit stones imbued with humankind's never-ending dreams.
Cool, Tecmo.
Since time immemorial, this power has been...
Dynasty warriors.
The impetus for human wars.
Spirit...
Why is she British?
Spirit scones?
It's the spirit scones.
My favorite game, finally got its equal.
That's not ace combat.
What makes a shogun?
Are you telling lies?
Sneaky.
Ninja.
Naruto.
Nioh, oh.
Nioh 3.
I like everything, it's unfair.
I'm just teasing you.
You can only like one game.
Takechiyo.
Konnichiwa!
That voice did not come from that kid.
If you think a voice that doesn't suit someone, listen to Japanese Raiden.
People in Japan think Raiden from Metal Gear Solid 2 was so cool.
His voice was really great.
It did not suit him.
But he is really cool.
It suits him.
That's it.
No one knows how old the city really is.
VR.
For me, it's all I've ever known.
My whole world.
Oh.
A public execution.
I was raised in this city's shadow.
Someone said that there was going to be a Ace Combat Zero remake.
Shame that was fake.
No.
To survive.
I want to play Oblivion.
That's me!
That's me when I unlock a chest.
That I'm really good at it.
This city hides many lost and legendary treasures.
Locked away.
Waiting to be...
Oblivion!
You have violated the law.
Waiting to be taken.
Stop!
You have violated the law.
E-Tina.
That was one thing also, you guys.
E-T-shirts were all over in Japan.
Thief VR.
Woah.
Yeah, there were E-T-shirts all over in Japan.
I was losing my mind.
I was like...
Tidewalker.
Are you there yet?
Oh.
It's so colorful.
At first, I thought this was...
Um...
Uh...
What's that swimming game?
The diving game?
Where you...
Are you crashing the alien planet?
It's gone!
Someone beat us to it!
Subnautica!
Yeah, yeah.
I thought it was that at first.
The guy?
Wait...
Ever since the great flood...
Elend...
My dear planet...
Has been dying.
I thought it was Subnautica at first.
You're taking everything from us.
But you type...
There are a game that just showed...
The disembodied heads to make you think you're playing every time.
And it's up to you now.
Wait, you're just fall...
Wait...
To use that power.
Is that Discord?
Wait, what?
Wait...
Hold on.
To you now.
To use that power.
Was it me?
Sorry.
I thought it was in the game.
It was...
But...
I should have stream remote on.
Weird.
I thought maybe somebody accidentally...
Had their discord open while they were airing this.
You know?
Silly... That's a fish.
Silly.
Silly state of play.
Yeah, you.
Me!
Yeah, me!
Tides of tomorrow... Hi, I'm Nicholas Doucet, the game director of Astrobot.
It's a pleasure to be back today to share more news with you.
No.
What the last few months it has been in the world of Astro.
Wait, more?
Did you just say more news?
After we launched last September to search encouraging feedback, even receiving a few others, we are truly greatly for.
In October, we added five speedrun levels, followed by a Christmas special packed with festive surprises.
And then earlier this year, the Vicious Void Galaxy made its appearance, adding yet more new challenging levels, out of which came at no additional cost.
And today, I am pleased to announce that later this month...
You will be able to enjoy five brand new challenge levels in Astrobot, bringing the total to a whopping 90 planets.
And new special bots will be there too, including Atsu from Ghost of Yotei, alongside other fans' favorites.
But these ones are a surprise.
And finally, the Astrobot DualSense wireless controller will return later this year, with a slight twist.
So be on the lookout for more news coming soon.
From all of us at Team Asobi, thank you all.
Go for the amazing reception you gave our game, and enjoy the rest of the show.
Astrobot!
I saw somebody say that this, that I would really like this state of play, that it was like, made for me.
You got Metal Gear!
You got Silent Hill F!
You got Astrobot!
It's Peek!
Oh shit!
Come on!
Hi, Red!
Oh,
pirate.
Crab.
Why are they made of wood?
Wood people.
Wood.
Her?
Wow.
Sea remnants.
I forgot to ask you.
I just came really, really late.
How's the audio?
We're like halfway.
Oh!
It's this game.
Uh... It's good?
Okay.
Or maybe I was thinking of a different game.
Wasn't there a game like this?
No?
Nice, queen.
Journey.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come on.
Yes!
Okay,just.
And here we go.
Hello.
Hey everyone!
I'm Place One Zatani.
That was a new look at Sword of the Sea, a visually striking adventure from the team behind Abzu and The Pathless.
We're excited to announce that Sword of the Sea will launch this summer into the PlayStation Plus game catalog.
On June 17th, Remedy brings otherworldly action to Game Catalog with FBC Firebreak.
In this cooperative FPS set in the Paranatural World of Control, you and two fellow agents must confront and contain the reality-warping chaos found within the oldest house.
Fun in short bursts or deep dives, FBC Firebreak launches day one in the Game Catalog on June 17th.
Doom.
I want to play that new Doom game.
The PlayStation Plus Classics catalog welcomes several new titles this summer.
The PS2 version of legendary immersive sim Deus Ex arrives June 17th.
No way!
In July, Twisted Metal 3 and Twisted Metal 4 join the service just in time for the second season premiere of Twisted Metal.
Wait, I wanted to play Deus Ex.
It arrives July 31st in select countries, including Peacock in the U.S.
Additionally, two of Capcom's most beloved games from the original PlayStation are set to join the Classics lineup.
Resident Evil 2 and Resident Evil 3 will arrive later this summer in the Classics catalog.
Additionally, Myst and Riven will arrive later this month as part of the Days of Play celebration, running now through June 11th.
Days of Play is a two-week event that includes bonus PlayStation Plus content drops, great deals on software and hardware, and more.
Visit PlayStation Blog and PlayStation.com for full details.
I was just thinking of that game the other day.
His parents cut their own rope to save him.
He watched them fall, then found his way off that mountain.
Is this a Mount Everest Climbing Simulator?
He then started a grand tour of every major boarding school in Britain.
Wait, did that just say Bond?
James Bond?
His superiors all praise his instincts.
And they're all in need of early retirement.
Nobody knows what to do with him, Mom.
Seven.
No.
And I suspect he feels the same way.
But what he did in Iceland...
Jimmy...
What he did in Iceland was insubordination.
It was ill-disciplined, utterly reckless.
He only survived thanks to blind luck.
Give me one good reason to put him in the program, Mom.
I think you just covered them all, Greenway.
Ooh.
It's really quite simple.
Bond is a bullet without a target.
Let's give him one.
Tom...
What the hell did they do?
That lion...
Do you have an appointment?
The name's Bond.
Tom Cruise?
He's with me.
And you are?
Don't think we've had the pleasure.
Hello?
Tom Cruise?
Tom Bond.
Omega.
Wait, oh god.
It's all gonna be like, licensed stuff, huh?
We're facing a situation of the utmost delicacy.
I need all my pieces on the board.
Kelly.
Double O9 is a master manipulator.
Double...
Nine?
We won't see it coming.
We went up two numbers.
A mid?
A flag.
Kiss me every time.
She's not your friend.
Oh, la, la.
She's an asset.
With respect, Mom.
To hell with that.
Blue O9 is another guy.
No kidding.
What?
Fuck.
Lately, headhunting.
Huh?
Why are you looking at her like that?
Women.
You know.
No!
Nine!
I suppose this is another... teachable moment... Nine!
Earn the number!
Wait, so do you go up?
You don't go down?
You don't start as 001?
You start at... wait... or... Yeah, so you start at like 001?
You start at 100?
And then you go, 099?
There's nine 00 guys.
They're titles.
They're showing off the watch again.
Everyone!
Crafting an experience that honors the legacy of Bond.
Harnessing our 25 years of agent expertise.
This is just the beginning of our journey with 007.
And we can't wait to share more with you soon.
Look at that smirk.
That guy was like, mm-hmm.
I can't do it right now, but...
001 is nuts.
Nanya tried.
How much more we got?
About 10 minutes more.
Agent 80085.
That's me!
Ghost of Minto.
Yeah, this is the new Ghost of Tsushima game, though.
Still with me?
I don't remember what it was called.
Ghost of Yotei.
Oh, a dog.
Oh, put that dog.
Oh,
boy.
Easy, boy.
Bow, bow, bow, bow.
Ghost of Yotei.
Gameplay Deep Dive coming in July.
It's an announcement for an announcement.
Oh, is it, uh... Oh!
Eh... Marvel fighting game?
Oh!
Wait, it looks awesome!
Who are you?
Daishori!
Da- Star-Lord!
La- Chris Pratt!
Who are you?
Oh!
Oh, that's Ghost Rider, no?
Yeah, baby!
Ah!
He has the ride!
Ah...
Doctor Doom!
Doctor Doom's Free Fall!
Uh...
Wow, there's some...
Oh!
Damn, she's hot!
Storm!
Yeah, yeah, Storm!
This looks kind of awesome!
4v4!
That's crazy!
Can you even tell what's going on in the screen?
He looks so awesome!
NotEd основ as otros!
Oh!
Noted now, baby!
Oh,
Iron Man looks too cool!
He looks too awesome!
A little pause...
We're going back to Metal Gear, baby!
Oh...
Yokohama...
Real...
Real footage...
I was like, I'm gonna say this.
So I was first off with my friend...
We had a question from S-S-E-R-P-R-E-U-P-R-E-R-E-R-E-R-E-R-E-R-S-E-R-E-R-E-R.
We introduced...
We did have an episode of Marvel's game, which was...
I was like, what is it?
We lived in the universe.
I first started collaborating with them.
It's a really famous IP, and I'm so proud of it.
But first, I'm really worried about it in my company.
It looks like...
It reminds me of My Hero Marvel.
I guess the character designs, you know?
The inspiration for working on this project really came from a place of pure fandom.
And wanting to say, why isn't PlayStation in this space?
So PlayStation approached us with this vision to bring Marvel back to the forefront of the tag fighting genre.
And that got us really excited because we've worked with that before on successful stuff like the Marvel Spider-Man franchise with Insomniac.
But this actually looks good.
When it came to approaching Marvel, you have to kind of first float the idea and let them know, hey, you know, we're thinking about approaching a company like Arc System Works to make a fighting game.
And we'd love to partner with you to do this really great collaboration.
Would you be interested?
When they named the developer, that really perked up our ears.
It's always refreshing to work with a team that will take on the challenge of tackling Marvel, putting their own spin on it, and they're just uppercutting that challenge into the stratosphere.
And that's what you get with this team.
I mean, they couldn't make something boring if they tried.
If you want to make something really well, you can do it.
But, as far as I've been talking about, this is my favorite part of Marvel.
The tricky thing is that most fans...
Is Spider-Man not Marvel?
What about every single Spider-Man game that's...
What are you talking about that they have no games?
Even if it's shovelware, they still have games.
Because you either do something like this vegan boy, or you don't do it at all.
I feel like I have a good grasp on their art style and how they would approach certain IPs.
That was so new.
You come in with your kind of own expectations of...
See what I would expect to see from Arc System Works when they take on a Marvel IP.
And what came up was something that went beyond that.
They look so cool!
Ah, thank you for the breeze!
Hello, hello!
Sorry, my arm's almost over now.
Yeah, hello.
Thank you for the breeze!
I remember personally, the first time I saw...
Iron Man was really when I felt we had something special.
We're watching the State of Plague because I didn't get to watch it yesterday.
We had something special.
So, if you guys want to watch Iron Man's design, you can see the design of Iron Man's design.
Iron Man's design is too cool!
It's a pretty Japanese-like Arc System Works-like design.
Looks too cool!
It's so cool!
It's like, oh, this is this!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Iron Man is supposed to be this sleek fighter jet.
I think luxury race car mixed with a brick house.
And the fact that they added anime and mech elements to him just felt really natural at home.
He's a brick!
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
One of the mantras that we have for this project is from Japan to the world, and really trying to take not just the IP but gameplay mechanics and say, what can we really take from Japan, the creators that are doing awesome work here, and bring that to the global platform.
I like Iron Man's design the most.
I think.
When ARK looks at these Marvel characters, it's not simply just the visuals.
It's also the game plan mechanics.
Look at that dinosaur!
But I also really like Ghost Rider's design too.
It looks really good.
We've seen tag fighters that have 2v2, 3v3.
We felt like we just had to go 4v4.
And in doing so, we found a lot of unique and fun ways to change up the gameplay that I think players are going to be very excited to see.
Too much!
There's too much happening on this screen!
The screen is like this big!
And there's...
Holy cow!
Too many cooks!
You can play out as just the leader and 3 assist.
Or you can tag in your assist to swap the leader and change the matchup on the fly.
I don't think a lot of people thought...
I like the way Ghost Rider plays too.
It looks cool.
Well, this has just been an awesome journey and I'm excited that we get to be able to share it with all the fans.
64 vs 64!
So true!
They never get to experience this level of production.
And it's just a dream to even be working with these two great partners.
Oh, she cute.
She cute too.
The three companies have come together to do this, and I think we really are going to make something magical here.
Oh, my arms are broken.
Oh, sorry.
Stay tuned.
I got to disappear for a second.
Is that it?
You're still with me?
Oh, no.
Yeah, I am.
I'm here.
Oh.
Oh, that was it.
Snake, take this!
The upcoming battle is truly unavoidable.
Silent Hill.
Show him again for me.
Not bad.
I don't want to see this baby man.
Oh, man.
Wow.
Silent Hill.
F.
What did it say?
September.
I remember...uh... It's like 20-something?
25th?
2025.
Thanks for watching.
Yay!
That was fun.
That was good.
Everything I liked was in it.
Now, once I have Silent Hill...
and once I have Metal Gear...
and then even more Astro Bot...
What am I supposed to do?
What?
What am I After Alive for?
Synapse, thank you so much for the alcohol!
Thank you!
Thank you.
Doom?
Yeah.
Doom.
Yeah, Doom.
It's a lot of video game.
Yes, indeedy.
Oh!
Yes.
Well, guys...
Um...
Probably...
No stream tomorrow.
But, um...
I'll have one on Saturday.
So, if you're like...
Don't be doing it!
Uh...
I'll see you Saturday.
And I'll be back to 2D.
2...
Why can't I ever get my fingers right?
I can't get them right!
Whatever, it's fine.
I'm gonna take it off.
I'm okay.
High five!
Hatsukashi.
Big beat, so cute.
Good job.
I'm right next to you.
I'm looking at you.
Are you being good?
Hmm?
Say thank you for that.
Kazuma, thank you!
Uh...
Your absence is...
Always acutely felt.
Ah!
Thank you, though.
Thank you.
Welcome back, Vito.
Thank you!
So...
Yeah!
Um...
This is fun...
And...
Oh, let me...
Oh!
Big...
Break my toe.
What's going on with my eyes?
Ugh...
There's a little bit of glitchy stuff.
Just don't pay any mind to it.
Don't pay any mind...
To the glitches!
No!
No pay!
I didn't even touch that.
Freaky.
Freaky!
I'll...
I'll stand up for the last bit.
Oh...
I think I might have to reset.
But...
Thank you guys...
For...
Our...
Streaming today!
Thanks for welcoming me back.
Hopefully...
Even though there was some scuff...
Hopefully it was still fun...
To...
See me...
Wiggle around...
In 3D!
I figured since I probably...
Um...
Hold on...
I'm fixing my mic...
I figured since probably...
I should...
Not...
Try to be so...
Well...
I still screamed a little bit...
But I can't help it.
I just can't help it.
But I was like...
Maybe I can show my excitement...
More of my movements...
Than anything else, so...
Yeah.
So...
Thank you guys...
And...
Have a good night!
Have a good day!
And...
I'll see you...
When I see you next!
Okaerii!
Tadai-ibo!
Tadai-ibo Tadai-ima!
Get out of here!
Get.
Go!
Leave!
Oh, my arms are broken again.
Go!
Yeah...
Get...
Leave...
Get out of my back, Calvin!
Bye to you, and bye to you, and bye to you, and bye to you, and bye to you, and bye to you, and bye to you, and bye to you, and bye to you, and bye to you, and bye to you, and bye to you, and bye to you, and bye to you, and bye to you, and bye to you,
and bye to you, and bye to you...
And why is my skirt broken?
What's going on?
Everything's breaking!
Oh, that's why.
There we go.
Bye to you and bye to you and bye to you and bye to you and bye to you and bye to you and bye to you.
Bye to you.
The viewer.
Hi dog.
Hi.
Die!
Okay.
Bye-bye.
What's up, Vito?
I'm gonna go sleep.
I'm gonna go be a baby.
Actually, I'm kind of hyped now.
I'm gonna go re-watch the trailer like 15 more times.
Times 100.
Bye-bye.